(dramatic orchestral music)
- First of all I want to say thank you.
Everyone's a fan, a serious fan.
I'm keeping my cool right
now, even when you walked in,
but we're all super big fans here,
and I'm gonna be chill about it.
But I wanted to do
something sweet for you,
so we made it a little afternoon
delight, a spot of tea,
because of how the Brits do.
So, feel free, pour.
(orchestral music)
- Nicely brewed.
- Is that coffee?
- So we did all right?
- This is tea.
- This is tea it's all tea.
- In a coffee pot?
- Earl grey.
- [Hugh] In a coffee pot.
- We thought we'd throw
you off a little bit, Hugh.
(laughing)
- What makes that possible-
- Hugh is all of a sudden my favorite.
- I think traditionally the coffee pot
is the slightly taller one.
- Oh, it is.
- The belly of this
allows the tea to brew,
the leaves to brew you see.
- To get a full bodied--
- Yeah.
- aroma.
- That's my theory anyway.
- I love it.
I love it, we're learning.
Oh, can I have some of that?
- Of course.
- All right.
(orchestral music)
I didn't bring you here
just to sip some tea,
I wanted to spill some tea,
so I thought of a game.
I like to call it sip it and spill it,
and it's basically a very
sophisticated version
of Never Have I Ever, so I'm trying
to keep something very
American and trashy, classy.
(crowd laughing)
But, for example, sip it and spill it
if you ever locked yourself in a bathroom
with a glass of wine
because you have children
and you just want a minute to yourself.
See then I would take this bad boy,
and I'd drink the whole thing.
- I'd have to drink that
with you, I'm afraid.
(laughing)
- I'm like, I just need--
- Sorry.
- Mommy needs a minute.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- Okay, I have one.
Sip it and spill it if you've
ever rolled Easter eggs
while wearing a bonnet and dress.
(jazz music)
- It's you?
- [Michelle] It's Hugh.
- You wear a bonnet often?
(plates clattering)
Oh my God.
- But you know, it was Easter.
My friends said, "Put on a dress,
and let's roll the Easter egg
down the hills", so you know.
- This makes you my favorite
person at the table once again.
(laughing)
- You said that twice.
- I know, once again.
Okay wait, Hugh your turn.
- Sip it and spill it if
you've ever snogged Brad Pitt.
- Snogged means kissed right?
- Yes, kiss.
- Are you about to sip your tea?
- Shall I show you?
Well I'm just bit, you know just--
(coughing)
- Go Elizabeth.
- What's that story?
(crowd applauding)
- Somebody had to.
- Somebody had to sacrifice.
- I did it as a paid job
because we were on a set,
- What a beautifully paid job.
- acting in a part, yes, indeed.
There are worst ways to earn a living.
- Wow.
- So I was not complaining, but yeah.
He cut his teeth with me I think, yeah.
(crowd clapping)
- Nice
- As it were.
- Did you teach him how to snog as well?
- I made him, I made
him the man that he is.
- You made him a good snogger?
- Yes, he's learned everything--
- I always love that y'all call it that
because it sounds not cool.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- Okay, your turn Allen.
- Sip it and spill it if you've ever put
on a Downton costume, or
any costume, backwards.
- Oh.
- You did, wait what?
What do you mean backwards?
How did you do that?
- It used to happen a lot
because sometimes the costumes
are the same on the front
as they are on the back
so there'll be like an
embellishment on the front
and you know a slightly
maybe varied pattern
on the back, but you can't
really tell the difference
so it happened a few times.
- How far did you go with it I mean--
- I actually turned up on set--
- Is it on camera?
- and went the neck feels really high
and the back's a little low.
(laughing)
So yes, I have.
- Sip it and spill it, if after
a night of wild carousing,
you ended up sleeping in your trailer
on the set of Downton Abbey.
(laughing)
Huh?
- Oh gosh!
- It's a true story.
- I remember this night so well.
- Maybe you know it's a long day.
It was during summer where
we have a light refreshment.
So we got very very refreshed
on hard cider called Old Rosie.
She's a cruel mistress because--
- She sounds fun.
- Oh, she was fun.
But she's great.
So I had the great idea, "I'll
just go back to the castle,
I'll sleep in the castle",
or like, in my trailer.
And then so basically
I'll be ready for work.
I'll just roll out of the
trailer but the problem is,
there's a 15 foot gate outside
of the castle so I was like,
"Uh it's gonna take all
of my MacGyver skills".
- You scaled the gate?
- I did.
It wasn't the greatest idea I've ever had.
(laughing)
Eh, I'm gonna be honest I was like--
- Can I say something else?
- Yeah.
- It's pitch black like you can't even--
- begin to describe--
- It's out in the countryside--
there's no
- because there's no light.
- Yeah yeah.
- I once tried, I drove
myself one day to the set.
All I had to do was drive to the gate.
I couldn't even find the gate.
- Did the car not have headlights?
- Yeah it had headlights but
they went like about two feet
and then it was black.
- The weak headlights.
(wheezing)
[Michele] And I didn't
understand because she said--
- And I was, I actually was in a ditch
and the wheels were
spinning and I couldn't get,
I couldn't actually get out of it.
(laughing)
(laughter drowns out sounds)
- And I was like--
(fake sobbing)
I'm not kidding.
- Oooh.
(laughing)
- Uh, sip it and spill it
if you've ever fallen out
of your tiny pair of speedo
swimming trunks while on set.
(laughing)
(mumbling)
(crowd laughing)
Why were you wearing speedos on set?
- It wasn't on Downton set, it
was on one of my first jobs.
The people who were doing
the costume wrote and said,
"Oh uh, a young boy and his father".
I was 17.
So when I arrived, all
of the speedos were like
for eight or nine year olds.
(laughing)
So then, and they were like,
"We don't have time just,
we're gonna have to, you
know, just, you're gonna
have to try and fit into one of them."
And then in one take they went,
"And okay just hold there".
And I said, "What", and
I was kind of agitated.
"What, what was the problem?"
They were like, "Your just, your um..."
(laughs loudly)
- It came out?
(laughing)
That is like...oh my gosh.
That's...horrifying.
- It was pretty embarrassing, yeah yep.
- Oh but kind of funny.
- That's why I can't
even look at a speedo.
(laughing)
- By the way, grapes?
- Fig?
- Thank you.
- Wait, what is that because
I actually don't know what that is.
- It's a fig.
- Fig.
- Do you just eat it like that?
I've only seen it as like
a spread or some sort.
- It's a real technique, I'll show you.
- Okay, it's a real technique?
(laughing)
Hugh, you're awesome.
All right, sip it and
spill it if you've had
the greatest time ever
at the most amazing--
(cheering)
(cheering drowns out sounds)
- Exactly, Hugh.
- [Hugh] You never do that.
You would never do that.
- Oh well you do in America, Hugh.
- Oh sip it and stuff it, Hugh.
- Sip it and stuff it.
(laughing)